how was your meeting yesterday I thought
the meeting went well yesterday I
thought the meeting went well the
agreement where are the disagreement I
don't think we have any sticking
points oh another reason there must be
no deal the immigration issue is a huge
drag on Democrats finally got their
attention take what just happened in the
house a rare bipartisan legislative
rebuke of Biden for his disastrous open
border policies 14 Democrats every
single Republican in the house voted to
denounce the nightmare that Biden's team
created for America now the immigration
issue is a top uh of the top voters
concerns now going into this election
cycle Biden gets 18% approval on the
issue who gives them the 18% the cartels
now that's a big reason why Senate
Republicans I think are so desperate to
save Biden they and their donors want to
keep a large flow of migrants coming in
they don't care about what happens to
the hospitals and they're afraid that
the issue could cost Biden this election
year so I think at some point we just
have to assume that McConnell's top
priority other than maybe funding the
war in Ukraine is getting Biden
reelected any notion that a border deal
passed now is going to be better than
anything Trump can do is
ludicrous what needs to be done to
enforce the Border can be accomplished
now through executive action as
president Trump said on Truth social
this is all easy to do and he'll do it
right away if he's elected and of course
he's right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else